Living down here on Earth it’s easy to forget
that we have it pretty good, at least in terms
of our environment not doing everything it
can to destroy us and everything we love.
But that’s not the case in space, and scientists
have had to solve all sorts of challenges
to keep space stations, probes, and satellites
functioning in such an extreme environment.
For example, they have to engineer their way
around problems like temperature.
Space can be extremely cold; the background
temperature of space is minus two hundred
seventy degrees celsius in the shade, just
a few degrees above absolute zero.
But in direct sunlight radiation can warm
a spacecraft hundreds of degrees, especially
when it’s closer to the sun.
Temperature extremes can damage or shatter
delicate equipment, and depending on the mission,
engineers will have to either insulate their
spacecraft from the cold or protect it from
the heat.
Sometimes they’ll have to do both!
The European Space Agency’s Rosetta mission
had to chase down a comet.
To get there Rosetta had to do several planetary
flybys before heading out towards the asteroid
belt.
On its ten year journey it went through wild
temperature fluctuations, so to overcome this
engineers fitted Rosetta with metal slats
or “louvres” that could open to let heat
radiate away or close to trap it and keep
the probe warm.
Comets like the one rosetta caught leave a
trail of dust in their wake, and are frequently
the cause of meteor showers we see on Earth.
Those little dust particles can also pose
a threat to spacecraft because they’re traveling
at thousands of kilometers per hour.
These can have the effect of sandblasting
solar arrays, harming optics, or damaging
the structure outright.
The best strategy is avoidance -- chart a
course where you don’t think there’s going
to be a lot of debris, but if it’s unavoidable
there’s still measures you can take.
When the Hubble telescope passes through a
meteor shower, scientists will rotate it so
those big solar panels are edge-on to the
incoming hazard, minimizing its surface area
like a fencer standing sideways.
But even if a spacecraft can keep itself at
the right temperature and avoid physical impacts,
there’s another hazard that will always
get them in the end.
Spacecraft are exposed to extreme radiation,
mostly in the form of high-energy charged
particles.
These particles can come from the sun or just
be zipping around the galaxy as cosmic rays.
They can also be trapped by the Earth’s
magnetic field and form enormous bands of
protons and electrons called Van Allen belts.
Not only do these particles pose a threat
to humans, but they can damage the electronics
of spacecraft as well.
They can cause a current to flow on the surface
of the craft, or burn out chips.
They can even change the contents of memory
cells, corrupting data the spacecraft’s
computers need to function.
If the computers fail or valuable data gets
corrupted, the whole mission can be a bust,
so engineers have to come up with strategies
to protect electronics from radiation in space,
what’s known as “space hardening.”
They can try and shield the electronics, but
shielding is heavy and weight adds cost to
the launch.
Spacecraft can have redundant electronics,
like three chips performing the same operation
simultaneously.
If radiation causes one to make an error,
the other two can check its work and overrule
it.
This way they can just use commercial electronics,
which are cheaper.
Interestingly, electronics today are more
sensitive to space radiation than they were
in the 60s and 70s.
To make them more robust the chips themselves
can be designed in such a way that makes them
resistant to radiation.
Designing hardened chips is difficult and
expensive though, and one of the most popular
chips still in use has the processing power
of a laptop from almost two decades ago.
Even with all these precautions, even the
best space-born electronics will still fail
eventually.
For more epic stories of innovation that shaped
our future, check out TheAgeOfAerospace.com
If you like this video don’t forget to subscribe.
Despite the challenges we have launched an
absurd number of satellites up there.
Is there room for any more?
Amy covers that here.One cool thing about
Rosetta’s louvres is they opened and closed
automatically.
The springs were temperature sensitive because
of the metals they were made of and so they
used no power.
Thanks for watching and stay tuned to Seeker!